bonjour ici patrice roy on it avaient
tous canada alain bérard l'un dernier
m'avait lancé un défi de faire leur s
banque est alain d'amener martin rémy
martin c'est une terrible maladie dont
on vous a souvent parlé bruno bono
niveau
notre vient c'est encore d'internement
en 2012 c'était foudroyant les rues
le maïs époque était devenue virale a
dormi à nous mêmes qu'on critique et ça
sans donner des millions de la
renaissance à donner de meilleures
recherches
alors cette année on refait tout ça on
est les premiers temps c'était au moins
12 jusqu'au bout mais on va continuer à
septembre si on rappelle que les gens
font des dons ses projets sur mounir
inside de la recherche
près ça aide aussi mais mon rythme
martin a pu bénéficier vérifie cette
année
alors on y va
1 2 3 go aux choses qui fait chaud